Cheyenne Trails has a great team Gloria
the manager and Miguel the maintenance
supervisor are always on top of
everything and they have a beautiful
Community program requires us to have
three inch screws in the doors to make
it safer that way they can't break down
a door is easy
we're also required we have some
landscape requirements that the
landscape has to be pruned and so you
can't have anybody hiding behind it
um
huge the biggest part of the program is
lighting safety yeah that there's enough
light at night to keep every area lit up
that way residents can feel more
comfortable going to and from their
vehicle the relationship between
Metro and the Northeast area command and
also my property manager and the
maintenance supervisor
that relationship helps build a stronger
community
it helps the residents become
become more active in their Community
here at the property and they also
assist the manager and the maintenance
supervisor in reporting any activity
that they're uncomfortable with